what who it is Tara in a dim dark street
of a dim dark city in a dim dark house
of that dim dark street in a dim dark
bedroom of that thin dark house under a
dim dark beds in that dim dark bedroom
lives a dim dark figure kögel Hara and
in the dimmest and darkest of times
tarik rules from under the bed with a
heart as black as the night Tara only
seeks to cause dread a cloak hides a big
euless body soulless eyes are all you
can see is it a boy or is it a girl Tara
didn't spotted easily with a thirst for
fear to be frenched Tara cruelly preys
on the weak with a sharp tongue and cold
stare hands that grasp you until your
shrink good bad big small poor or which
Tara simply doesn't care you'll be
hunted down and never found with fate
worse than a nightmare terror can be
anyone and anywhere so beware
because in your dim dark street in your
dim dark city in your dim dog house of
your dim dark street in your dim dark
bedroom of your dim dog house and your
dim dark bed in your dim dark bedroom
lives Adam dark figure called terra and
in the dimmest and darkest of times Tara
crawls from under your bed
you
hey thanks for watching my video all
about terror this was actually a
interactive video experience that I
created for a Razzie pie exhibition
called the creative technologist
exhibition if you want to find out more
about how I turned this video into an
interactive experience using the Razzie
pie circuit boards programming and other
tech things like that then check out my
videos on how i did it all over on my
line with yagmur next channel the links
will be in the description below check
it out I would love for you to see what
I did with this and I really hope you
enjoyed it as well that'll be Darrington
Tara